e tornato da una puntata di cucina
buttata ho bisogno in realtà di una
musica di pathos ho bisogno di mission
impossible come come effetto perché
finalmente non hanno permesso il
prossimo tipo trainer può finalmente ce
l'abbiamo fatta ragazzino ho cercato
ovunque su internet per trovare la
ricetta della vita il gelato da fare in
casa in cinque minuti regione grazie
alla nostra
ho trovato una ricetta grazia fanpage ad
altri siti americani che spiegano come
fare il gelato in cinque minuti o se
funziona
io ho trovato la svolta io voglio
solamente commenti di grazie lasciateci
di sotto lasciateci sotto ogni speranza
voi che entrate
se veramente questa ricetta funziona
stiamo nella fantascienza a cavallo
posso avere un i territorio mamma
un'unione fra un cavallo è una strega
non ridere se questo è quella gara
felicità gente
per fare il gelato in cinque minuti
avremmo bisogno di un fegato latte panna
fresca gocce di cioccolato e basta basta
in realtà avevamo bisogno anche di
questi sacchetti nei del sale grosso e
di ghiaccio congelato no convinto fatto
prendiamo questo misuratore factotum
perché con questo caso abbiamo fatto
qualsiasi cosa 100 grammi di latte
fresco intero aspetta qui non c'è la
tacca dei 100 quindi non fa l'occhio
cioè assurdo che sia così facile fare
questo genere
no è assurdo si aspetta il momento dopo
perché quella la follia del 900 grammi
di panna la mano di un chirurgo vorrei
semplicemente dire a 40 grammi di
zucchero 40 ragazzi oggi è ora secondo
me la cosa migliore è che consiglio è
utilizzare una bustina più piccola e una
più grande perché poi questa bustina
piccola dovrà entrare in quella più
grande per raffreddarsi ve lo faccio
vedere dopo ha quindi prendiamo la
bustina piccola è rimasto tutto zucchero
qua dentro
leggere sulla dentro
dimentico presentati uno schifo e
diverte molto vuoi provare la
soddisfazione prendiamo delle gocce di
cioccolato e mettiamoci nel qb
quantobasta grembiule conseguendo sarro
questa volta le tasse così funziona su
culla di cioè b è ok credo di aver
esagerato
ma adesso non sono ciò che lo aspetta
questo ma esplode non fa del palloncino
come ho fatto io io spero le funzioni
sono veramente curioso lo sai che ho
pensato alla stessa batteria pensato e
ho pensato non la dico perché la
prendevano a questo punto la busta più
grande
apriamo la e riempiamo la di ghiaccio
arrivato subito che viene qui hai a
inquadrare il disastro è grazie cucino
la cucina del cugino il cugino
almeno però sono pronto posso dire che
invece con questo colore chic
scusate qui facciamo anche moda qualcuno
criminalità grazie a una grande
differenza fra la criminalità e topolino
prendiamo il sale grosso e lo buttiamo
dentro ora teoricamente il sale insieme
al ghiaccio creano una reazione per cui
la temperatura all'interno di questo
sacchetto dovrebbe abbassarsi
ulteriormente
e come se il sale dirà se fuori il
ghiaccio glaciale del ghiaccio bello il
meglio del ghiaccio grazie infiliamo il
nostro sacchetto chiudiamo per 5 minuti
soltanto dovremmo teoricamente
massaggiare il tutto così
delicatamente col terrore che esploda da
un momento all'altro giusto nemmeno se
si è bucato nel sacchetto mai grazie
veramente educato non lo gira il palermo
nel cambio voglio il cambio foto manca
ok ma dai che cos'è nodo è la cosa perso
tutto e lasciare il tempo è relativo
beh il tempo è relativo ma non fatemi
facciamo altri cinque minuti abbiamo
detto fare sulla neve per fare la scion
quando a roma di biggar si dentro mi
sale così larinesi storie non mi torna
allora questo possiamo vedere su
internet perché si mette il sale
allora facciamo anche informazione il
gelato sta diventando più scuro prima
era proprio bianco e adesso invece sta
prendendo un colorito sono un altro
negozi sicuri di vista degli altri
settori cosiddetti gradoni di tale
scelta che insidia che si ghiaccia che
però molti l'alzano per liberare le
strade
ma perché mettere tour a levi di entrate
il valore passando di ingordi proviamo a
vedere cosa uscito
cioè gocce di cioccolato e gelato ma di
base sarebbe venuta così possiamo
tranquillamente
ritorniamo illustri di sempre noi
ricette andate bene si ritorna a creare
roba abominevole
le due si erano giuste vabbè la certezza
che sei in tornato sui classici binari
di cuciniamo buttato cioè non era
cattivo era semplicemente molto molto
molto acquoso scusate se qualcuno
proverà a fare questa cosa ok a casa sua
anche se io lo sconsiglio caldamente
fatemi sapere cosa avete fatto di
fantasmagorico se vi riuscirà
attaccatevi su instagram tocca temi dei
nostri stories pagatemi nei vostri post
fate quello che vi pare l'importante è
che qualcuno che conosca un metodo
veloce per fare il gelato a casa senza
bisogno della gelatiera me lo faccia
sapere qua sotto come sempre l'invito ad
attivare la campanella per venire
aggiornato ogni volta che uscirà un
nuovo video ed io vi invito a lombardo
che brutta cosa sapere che domani non
vedere l'alba di un nuovo giorno perché
noi ci vediamo la prossima settimana con
un'altra ricetta
ciao grazie mille ragazzi intanto alla
faccia mostra me lo finisco tranquillo
vi invitiamo a 4